here is just a clip just to really sum  up the difference in the positions  between Mehmet Oz and John fetterman on  this issue all I want women doctors  local political leaders letting the  Democracy that's always allowed our  nation to thrive to put the best ideas  forward so states can decide for  themselves contrast that with my  opponent John Federman but if you  believe that the choice for abortion  belongs between you and your doctor  that's what I fight for it's it's that  that's it's that simple it's that simple  and Oz's position of course has been  cobbled together in trying to basically  focus group the best possible thing to  say exceptions but not this and no  federal involvement but let local it's a  mess and it's outrageous and it's  extreme the fetterman position is the  correct position